Herzlich willkommen zu Forscher Geist, dem Podcast des Stifterverbands für die Deutsche Wissenschaft, mein Name ist Tim Pritlove. Und ich begrüße alle hier zu einer neuen Ausgabe, die mich heute mal nach Hamburg geführt hat. Und heute wollen wir so ein bisschen über fortgeschrittene Weltrettung sprechen, so würde ich es mal ganz salopp einleiten wollen. Und ich begrüße als Gesprächspartner Michael Braungart. Schönen guten Tag.
Guten Tag.
Herr Braungart, Sie sind Wissenschaftler? Würden Sie sich selber so bezeichnen?
Ich habe Chemie und Verfahrenstechnik studiert. Habe eine Doktorarbeit gemacht, habe verschiedene Professorenstellen, einen Lehrstuhl in Rotterdam und dann muss ich ja Wissenschaftler sein sozusagen.
Kann man so sagen. Wie sind Sie es denn geworden?
Ich hatte eine sehr nahe Beziehung zu meiner Chemielehrerin, als ich 16 war. Sie war 24 und sie muss noch ihre abschließende Prüfung schaffen und ich war Klassensprecher und dann habe ich meinen Mitschülern Chemie beigebracht und dadurch habe ich mich für Chemie interessiert und dann kam ja einige Jahre davor der Club of Rome Report über Grenzen des Wachstums heraus. Und dann konnte ich meiner bildungsbürgerlichen Familie sagen, warum Chemie so interessant ist. Und darum habe ich zielstrebig Chemie studiert und konnte dann in Aachen, Darmstadt, München, in Brüssel, in Hamburg wo immer ich etwas lernen konnte, bin ich hingegangen, um dann sozusagen zu lernen, wie Chemie in so einem Umweltthema anders aussehen kann.
Damals gab es noch keine eigenen Studiengänge dafür, also musste ich die Leute besuchen, so wie Sie halt zu den Leuten hingehen, musste ich zu den Menschen hingehen, um von ihnen zu lernen.
Dieser Club of Rome Report was hat er denn damals auf den Tisch gelegt?
Naja, der Report war im Prinzip ein Untergangsszenario, Grenzen des Wachstums, wenn wir so weitermachen, dann würde der Planet dem Untergang geweiht sein. Das war natürlich etwas naiv gedacht, aber im Prinzip natürlich schon richtig. Die Rohstoffe auf diesem Planeten sind begrenzt. Und wenn wir von der Wiege bis zur Bahre denken und dann die Materialien nachher in Müllverbrennungsanlagen oder Deponien abgeben, dann sind wir wirklich zu viele Menschen auf der Welt. Und die Grundbotschaft hat mich schon umgetrieben. Da die Chemie dann aber die wichtigste Wissenschaft ist, die Materialien zu bestimmen. Die Energieseite werden wir lösen, weil da gibt es genügend Sonneneintrag auf der Welt. 10.000 mal mehr als wir jemals brauchen werden. Aber die Materialseite, wir kriegen zu wenig Meteoriten von außen herein, darum hat mich die von Anfang an interessiert.
Also Sie meinen, das Material schwindet, weil wir es falsch verwenden?
Ja die Leute reden von Recycling, wenn sie zum Beispiel bei einem Auto 46 Metalllegierungen mit Kupfer, mit Chrom, mit Nickel, mit Mangan, mit Cobalt und Vanadium, mit allen seltenen Buntmetallen nachher zu Baustahl verarbeiten. Das wäre so, wenn Sie ein schönes schottisches Hochlandrind haben und nachher Hamburger draus machen. Das nennen wir Recycling. Oder aus einem Mobiltelefon werden von 41 Elementen genau 9 zurückgewonnen. Das nennt sich Recycling. Das ist eine Beleidigung wirklich normaler Wissenschaft dabei. Auf jeden Fall. Also was mir wichtig ist, ist zu verstehen, es geht mir nicht um Moral, also überhaupt nicht, weil die Moral ist immer dann weg, wenn man sie eigentlich braucht. Und da ich hauptsächlich, weil ich für meine Chemielehrerin geschwärmt habe, Chemie studiert habe, habe ich auch nie später gedacht, auch nicht zu Greenpeace-Zeiten, ich wäre jetzt moralisch ein besserer Mensch.
Nur wenn 10 Millionen Tonnen Plastik in den Ozeanen landen, dann ist ein Kunststoffchemiker einfach ein Idiot. Also das ist einfach primitivste Wissenschaft. Das ist eine Bankrotterklärung an Wissenschaft, die im Moment stattfindet im Umweltbereich. Und darum ist es wichtig, die besten jungen Leute dazu zu kriegen, sich wirklich in diesem Bereich zu engagieren, weil für Chemie gab es nach der Seveso-Katastrophe 1976 nie einen Numerus Clausus, bis heute nicht. Wir haben jeden Idioten genommen, den wir kriegen konnten, wenn er nur sagte, ich kann aber auch im Labor stehen, sozusagen. Und entsprechend hat sich die Chemieindustrie auch sehr wenig dynamisch weiterentwickelt, weil die besten Leute halt Bänker geworden sind, Juristen geworden sind, ins Internet gegangen sind. Und darum hat sich dieser Bereich so stürmisch entwickelt. Aber wenn Sie heute sagen, mein Bruder ist Bänker, dann sagt der, ja was für ein Schwein. So ging es den Chemikern damals. Und vor 10 Jahren, wenn Sie sagen, mein Bruder ist Bänker, dann hat der gesagt, was toll, wunderbar.
Und wenn Sie in fünf Jahren sagen werden, mein Bruder ist bei Google, dann werden Sie sagen, was für ein Schwein. Weil die Entwicklung geht genauso hin, dass die gesellschaftliche Anerkennung für diese Tätigkeiten drastisch abnehmen wird. Und mein Ziel ist jetzt, junge Leute zu motivieren, genau eben über Qualität zu arbeiten, nicht über Moral. Weil die Moral ist unter Stress immer weg, nicht nur in Deutschland.
Was ist denn überhaupt das Problem? Nur dass wir vielleicht erst mal die Dimensionen auch verstehen. Ich denke vielen von uns ist klar, wir leben in einer Überflussgesellschaft, also zumindest hier in Deutschland, alles ist irgendwie da, es gibt extrem komplexe Produkte und man nutzt die dann halt oder packt sie vielleicht auch nur aus. Und kippt es dann halt irgendwo hin. Also den Rest oder am Ende dann auch das Produkt selber. Sie hatten vorhin schon das Beispiel mit dem Auto genannt. Aber es sind ja noch sehr viel mehr Sachen, die wir täglich und dauerhaft verwenden. Wie groß ist das Problem, wie würden Sie das Problem, in dem wir gerade dort stecken, beschreiben?
Naja der Kaiser ist nackt. Also es fängt damit an, dass eine Stadt wie Hamburg möchte klimaneutral sein. Hört sich gut an, aber wenn Sie darüber nachdenken, ist das so ziemlich das traurigste, was Sie sich vorstellen können. Sie können nur klimaneutral sein, wenn Sie nicht existieren. Das heißt, schauen Sie sich einen Baum an, kein Baum ist klimaneutral. Ein Baum ist immer gut fürs Klima. Das heißt mit aller unserer Intelligenz wollen wir dümmer als Bäume sein. Oder stellen Sie sich vor, die aufgeklärten Leute essen gerne Bionahrungsmittel und es gibt kein Biosiegel, was erlaubt, dass meine eigenen Nährstoffe zurückgehen. Es ist nur Bio ohne mich. Also wir fühlen uns so schuldig, dass wir auf der Welt sind, dass wir sagen, es ist nur Bio, wenn meine eigenen Exkremente nicht zurück dürfen.
Dabei muss ich jeden Tag zwei Gramm Phosphat aufnehmen, zwei Gramm Phosphat abgeben, sonst kann ich keine Zähne haben, kann ich kein Knochen haben, keine Energie speichern im Körper. Phosphor ist viel seltener als Öl und wir hängen von zwei Ländern ab, die 70% der Vorräte kontrollieren. Durch den Phosphorbergbau wird viel mehr Radioaktivität in die Umwelt gebracht, als in allen Atomanlagen verwendet wird. Und dann denken wir, es ist nur Bio, wenn meine eigenen Nährstoffe nicht zurückgehen. Das heißt wir sind so ganz am Anfang dessen, weil wir denken, eigentlich sind wir Schädlinge auf der Welt. Wir wollen den ökologischen Fußabdruck minimieren. Und darum nehmen wir auch unterschwellig in Kauf, dass so viele Menschen im Mittelmeer ertrinken, weil wir denken, naja es sind sowieso zu viele, Überbevölkerung. Es wäre eigentlich besser, wir wären gar nicht da. Darum ist die erste Sache, zu fragen, sind die Menschen eine Chance für den Planeten oder eine Belastung? Wenn wir sie als Chance sehen, dann werden sie zu einer Chance. Wenn wir sie als Belastung sehen, dann werden sie zu Belastung.
Chance wofür?
Naja die anderen Lebewesen zu unterstützen. Also wir versuchen im Moment, nicht da zu sein. Und dafür sind wir zu viele. Wir denken es sei Umweltschutz, wenn wir ein bisschen weniger Schweinereien machen. Also schützt die Umwelt, fahr weniger Auto oder schütz die Umwelt, macht weniger Müll oder verbrauche weniger Wasser. Wie albern. Das wäre so, wenn ich sagen würde, schütz dein Kind, schlage es nur fünf mal anstatt zehn mal. Oder stellen Sie sich vor, Sie kommen nach Hause und sagen, ich bin heute kinderneutral, was für ein Depp. Aber in diesem Umweltbereich haben wir immer noch das Gefühl, es sei ein moralisches Thema. Und durch die Wiedervereinigung haben wir in Deutschland etwa 20 Jahre verloren. Weil wir sagten, die Moral können wir uns jetzt gerade nicht erlauben, weil wir ja um die Wiedervereinigung Geld brauchen. Darum sind wir in vielen Dingen im geistigen Stand auf dem Anfang der 90er Jahre stehen geblieben. Und jetzt erst wird begriffen, dass der Umweltbereich praktisch die einzige echte Innovationschance für die Europäer sind.
Wir können jetzt die 40 Jahre Weltuntergangsdiskussion in Innovation umsetzen, in Qualität. Nur wir sind jetzt auf dem halben Wege stecken geblieben. Wenn Sie zum Beispiel einen Ikea-Katalog in China drucken, dann enthält der etwa 90 giftige Stoffe. Wenn der in Europa gedruckt wird, dann hat der durch die Umweltdiskussion bedingt eben nur noch 50 giftige Stoffe drin. Das heißt aber, der Katalog kann nicht im Ofen verbrannt werden, wenn die Asche in die Landwirtschaft soll oder wenn ich die Menschen nicht vergiften will. Oder das Papier kann auch nicht kompostiert werden, obwohl es ja ein biologisches Material ist. Wo ist da jetzt der Unterschied, ob ich jetzt 50 mal erschossen werde oder 90 mal? Ich habe also wesensmäßig nichts erreicht. Ich habe nur wahnsinnig viel Geld ausgegeben und tatsächlich ist dabei wesensmäßig nichts anderes entstanden. Jetzt lohnt es sich, den Katalog in China zu drucken, ihn nach Frankfurt einzufliegen am nächsten Tag, er ist 40% billiger und wir machen dann das Hightech-Recycling für chinesischen Sondermüll und sagen, oh der Standort Europa ist so teuer geworden.
Was würde denn passieren, wenn wir jetzt nichts an dem Status quo ändern?
Also das erste ist, es gibt keinen Grund für irgendwelche Weltuntergangsszenarien. Also die Leute machen sich wichtig, indem sie die Katastrophe möglichst aufbauen. Die Welt wird nicht untergehen. Auch es geht nicht darum, dass die Menschheit sich auslöschen wird, nichts dergleichen. Ich kann mir alle Szenarien durchdenken, die irgendwie auch nur theoretisch sind. Es werden im schlimmsten Falle immer noch mindestens zwei Milliarden Menschen übrig bleiben. Also es geht nicht um das Ende der Menschheit. Auch die Natur wird nicht kaputte gehen dabei. Und es werden nicht nur die Kakerlaken übrig bleiben. Sondern ganz ganz viele Lebewesen. Was nur halt verschwinden wird sind alle Lebewesen, die uns besonders liebenswert erscheinen. Also die Elefanten oder die Tiger oder die Bären, das wird verschwinden. Und was damit verschwinden wird, mit beiden zusammen, es wird das verschwinden, worst case sozusagen, was uns Menschen menschenwürdig macht.
Wir würden uns kannibalisieren. Wir werden uns mit Verteilungskämpfen beschäftigen, und werden damit eben unsere eigene Würde einbüßen. Also darum im schlimmsten Fall. Wenn man jetzt ein anderes Szenario macht und sagt, hey komm wir werden jetzt nochmal alles neu erfinden, dann könnten wir leicht auch 30 Milliarden Menschen auf der Erde ernähren, ohne nur einen einzigen Baum abzuholzen. Wir könnten leicht ein viel gesünderes Leben dadurch haben und wir müssen bloß wirklich alle Dinge nochmal neu erfinden, wirklich ganz von Anfang. Und das ist kein technisches Thema erst mal. Es ist erst mal die Frage, was ist die Rolle der Menschen auf der Welt? Wir haben eine skandinavische Nachhaltigkeitsdefinition übernommen und die kann ich verstehen.
Wenn es dunkel und kalt ist, dann müssen sie sparen, verzichten, vermeiden, sonst kommen sie nicht durch den Winter. Darum auch der ökologische Fußabdruck, den müssen sie minimieren. Weil jeder in Schweden, in der Tundra jeder Fußabdruck den Boden zerstört. Aber wenn Sie entlang des Rheins laufen, dann bedeutet jeder Fußabdruck einen kleinen Retentionsraum. Also warum nicht ... der die Überschwemmung verhindert sozusagen, warum nicht einen großen Fußabdruck schaffen, der aber ein Feuchtgebiet wird? Also warum nicht den anderen Lebewesen was zu nutzen, dafür da zu sein. Nicht weniger schädlich zu sein. Bei uns ist das höchste ein Passivhaus. Gut, wenn Sie Sadomasogelüste haben, dann ist vielleicht ein Passivhaus für Sie etwas geeignetes, aber wir versiegeln die Gebäude, machen sie gasdicht, anstatt zuerst zu fragen, was ist gesunde Luft? Ich schlage vor, Gebäude zu machen wie Bäume. Gebäude, die die Luft reinigen. Gebäude, die das Wasser reinigen. Gebäude, die energiepositiv sind. Die Carbon-positive sind.
Weil die Erde hat einen Überschuss an Energieeintrag. Es müssen auf der Welt viel mehr Gebäude gekühlt werden als erwärmt. Also das Heizen ist praktisch die Ausnahme, wenn Sie sich das global anschauen. Und darum ist es höchste Zeit, von der Natur zu lernen. Aber nicht als Mutter, nicht was haben wir Mutter Natur angetan, wie Prince Charles, der dann die Augen rollt dafür oder Vandana Shiva, denn die Natur ist nicht unsere Mutter. Die am stärksten krebserzeugenden Stoffe sind Naturstoffe. Die Natur benötigt den Krebs, um den Genpool anzupassen. Das ist für das Individuum eine Katastrophe, aber für das Kollektiv die zwingende Voraussetzung. Die giftigsten Stoffe sind Naturstoffe, also bei weitem. Die Natur braucht Gifte, die sie ganz gezielt einsetzt, um eben dann bestimmte Effekte zu erreichen.
Nur die Natur ist nicht dumm. Wir können von der Natur endlos lernen. Sie ist unsere Partnerin, unsere Lehrerin, aber nicht unsere Mutter. Denn wenn wir sie zur Mutter erklären, dann machen wir uns immer klein und hässlich und sagen immer, ja wir sind die ungezogenen Kinder sozusagen, wir entschuldigen uns immer, dass wir überhaupt da sind. Dass wir älter als 30 werden liegt nicht an Mutter Natur, die Natur braucht uns da nicht. Wir werden lange Kompost sozusagen. Nein, es liegt an uns, an den Medizinern, den Leuten Hygienikern, an den Chemikern, an den Architekten, an den Ingenieuren. Und das können wir feiern. Wir müssen uns nicht entschuldigen, dass wir da sind.
Also so eine Reduktion von 6 Milliarden auf 2 Milliarden ist ja jetzt nicht ganz wirkungsfrei.
Also wir sind schon deutlich über 7 Milliarden.
Oh Gott, ich bin schon gar nicht mehr auf dem Stand der Dinge.
Nein, natürlich nicht, wir werden uns kannibalisieren, wenn wir in dieser Weise weiter machen. Und das ist ein schleichender Prozess. Also wir verlieren mit jedem Tag an Vitalität. Wir verlieren vier Jahre Lebenserwartung durch Feinstäube zum Beispiel. Drei Jahre durch Lärm zum Beispiel auch. Und wir werden zwar immer das reparieren können, aber unsere Vitalität büßen wir mit dem ersten Atemzug damit ein. Und am Schluss werden wir sicher 100 Jahre alt, aber mit Reparaturen. Das heißt wir brauchen wirklich alles nochmal neu. Und das fängt mit ganz einfachen Dingen an. Schauen Sie doch mal, wir haben 27 Millionen vollzeiterwerbstätige Menschen in Deutschland. Die sind für diese 21,8 Millionen Vollzeitrentner verantwortlich sozusagen. Im Bundeshaushalt wird fast ein Drittel ausgegeben, um die Renten zu bezahlen und die Renten zu subventionieren.
Von denen was wir jetzt haben, zusätzlich zu dem. Das kann nicht sein. Das funktioniert von Anfang an nicht. Als die Rente eingeführt wurde, war die Lebenserwartung der Leute genau halb so hoch wie heute. Heute ein 60-Jähriger hat ein biologisches Alter eines 40-Jährigen vor 100 Jahren. Wenn man den gleichen Prozentsatz in Rente schicken würde wie damals, dann wäre unser Rentenalter bei 88,2 Jahren. Wir haben die Rente damals nur eingeführt als Industriegesellschaft, für die Leute, die wir sonst nicht tot gekriegt haben. Und das kann nicht sein, dass wir jetzt die Leute mit 65 nach Mallorca entsorgen, das ist doch menschenunwürdig. Die Leute, die ich kenne, alle die auf Mallorca sind davon, die auch einen früheren Ruhestand gemacht haben, nach drei Jahren können Sie mit denen nichts mehr anfangen. Sie können sich über den besten Fisch unterhalten noch und den schönsten Strand und das tollste Restaurant. Und das ist es, die retardieren einfach und das ist menschenunwürdig.
Das heißt wir brauchen eine völlig andere Denkweise. Ich bin halt Chemiker, drum drückt sich das zunächst in Produkten und Materialien für mich aus, aber insgesamt geht es darum, die Dinge nochmal neu komplett zu erfinden. Wir brauchen ein Drittel soziale Tätigkeit. Also sich um Asylsuchende zu kümmern, brauchen wir wirklich Zeit, um uns um Kinder zu kümmern. Unsere Kinder brauchen von der Gesellschaft, nicht nur von den Eltern, viel mehr Aufmerksamkeit und viel mehr Zeit. Unsere Kranken brauchen viel mehr Zeit. Jemand der Alzheimer hat, der muss rund um die Uhr 1 zu 1 betreut werden. Und zwar mit einer Person, die nicht irgendwie ständig wechselt oder so was, sondern einfach mit einem Team von Leuten um die Person herum. Denn sonst büßen wir unsere Würde im Alter spätestens ein. Das heißt dafür brauchen wir Zeit. Dann sind wir ein Drittel traditionell erwerbstätig und ein Drittel werden wir in Zukunft für eine gartengebundene Landwirtschaft und für den aktiven Schutz der anderen Lebewesen einsetzen.
Eine gartengebundene Landwirtschaft ist viel produktiver als jede Monsanto-Gentechnik-Landwirtschaft. Sie kann viel gesündere Lebensmittel herstellen und sie kann vor allem auch die Menschen, die in einer beschleunigten Welt nicht mitkommen, auch mit beschäftigen. Und zwar menschenwürdig beschäftigen. Und damit werden wir aber in der Nahrungskette an anderer Stelle einsteigen. Wir versuchen, das Bestehende perfekt zu machen. Da jetzt das Bestehende aber falsch ist, machen wir es nur perfekt falsch. Als ich ein Kind war hat eine Kuh im besten Falle 5000 Liter Milch gegeben im Jahr. Heute sind wir in Holland in Wageningen bei 12000 Liter angekommen. Jetzt will ich aus dieser armen Kuh nochmal 1000 Liter mehr rausquetschen, damit ich effizienter bin? Oder soll ich doch eher fragen, was ist gesundes Essen? Also was ist gesunde Nahrung? Und dann kommen wir zu völlig anderen Antworten. Wenn ich Rindfleisch verspeise nehme ich gerade 20% des Eiweißes auf.
Ich will jetzt nicht sagen, es sollen alle Vegetarier werden, aber Rindfleisch ist eine Delikatesse, die man vielleicht am Sonntag mal verspeist. Oder mal so ein gutes Steak oder so was. Aber ein täglicher Hamburger ist eine Absurdität, das ist absolut ungesund. Das ist die ungesundeste Form von Eiweiß davon. Die Leute in Indien haben schon recht, wenn sie keine Kühe verspeisen sozusagen. Aber wenn man bei Algen einsteigt oder bei Bakterien, bei Pilzen, ist das Eiweiß viel gesünder, bei Algen nehmen sie über 90% des Eiweißes auf.
Also bräuchten wir jetzt mehr Algenburger sozusagen?
Naja wir haben in kurzer Zeit von den Japanern eine völlige Unsitte übernommen, einen rohen Fisch in Dortmund zu verspeisen. Das ist albern. Das Zeug ist hoch verkeimt, aber trotzdem finden wir es irgendwie schick. Die Leute in Japan essen etwa 150 verschiedene Algenarten. Das heißt wir können Algen ganz gezielt züchten. Stattdessen machen wir Maisanbau und füttern damit Hühner und Schweine. Oder machen sogar noch Biodiesel, noch viel dümmer sozusagen. 20% unserer landwirtschaftlichen Fläche wird nur für Biotreibstoffe verwendet. Sie können auf einem Hektar Algenanbau an Fassaden zum Beispiel so viel anbauen wie auf 80 Hektar Maisanbau. Und dabei stehlen Sie keine landwirtschaftliche Fläche. Und mit den Algen können Sie die Öle zum einen gewinnen und zum anderen das Eiweiß dabei. Wir haben diese Treibstoffe ausprobiert, auch mal in einer Fluggesellschaft. Sie können damit anstatt 1000 Kilometer sogar 1200 Kilometer weit fliegen mit diesen Ölen kaltgepresst sozusagen.
Und das ist beeindruckend, dass wenn man in der Nahrungskette einsteigt, können wir auch leicht 30 Milliarden Menschen auf der Welt ernähren. Wenn Sie die Bevölkerungsdichte der Holländer hochrechnen und sagen, okay. Wenn Sie das nehmen und das hochrechnen auf die jetzige landwirtschaftliche Fläche, dann entspricht das einer Erdbevölkerung von deutlich über 50 Milliarden Menschen. Und Holland ist das zweitwichtigste landwirtschaftliche Exportland weltweit überhaupt von allen, was die Wertschöpfung dort so angeht. Das heißt und das mit einer gartengebundenen Landwirtschaft, die natürlich noch völlig anders aussehen wird, aber das wäre sozusagen ein Beginn davon.
Holland als Vorbild?
Holland hat die höchste Bevölkerungsdichte in Europa und hat weltweit eine der fünf höchsten Bevölkerungsdichten überhaupt. Dadurch haben die natürlich viel Zivilisationsstress schon vorher erlebt und dadurch viele Dinge entwickelt. Holland hat als Gesellschaft sicher einen gesellschaftlichen Vorsprung von 10-15 Jahren gegenüber den anderen europäischen Ländern. Allein durch den Entwicklungsdruck, durch die beständige Bedrohung, durch das Meer natürlich zum einen, darum kann man in Holland auch nicht die Natur romantisieren. Wenn ich da das Haus in dem ich in Rotterdam lebe ist -8 Meter unterm Meeresspiegel. Wenn ich dort von Mutter Natur schwafeln würde, würde die nächste Flutwelle mich einfach mitnehmen. Das heißt man kann von Holland lernen, die Natur als Partner zu verstehen und nicht als Mutter sozusagen. Und wie gesagt, also dort setzt sich ja auch Cradle to Cradle viel schneller um, weil die Leute nicht fragen. In Deutschland fragen die, ist es moralisch, ist so geboten und dann vergessen sie halt die Moral, wenn sie sie brauchen. Und in Holland fragen die einfach nur, kann man damit Geld verdienen? Und darum habe ich einen Lehrstuhl an der wichtigsten Businessschool in Europa, die angesehenste davon, um zu zeigen, dass das wirtschaftlich sinnvoll ist, was ich tue.
Ich muss an der Stelle mal ein bisschen zusammenfassen und vielleicht auch den eigentlichen Fachbegriff, den Sie jetzt schon gerade haben fallen lassen, überhaupt erst mal einführen, weil bisher habe ich da ein wenig drum herum geredet. Also wenn ich jetzt so das verstehe, also persönlich sind Sie erst mal getragen aus einer Begeisterung für Chemie, was damals noch sehr unpopulär war. Verstanden, dass Chemie an der Stelle steht, ein Schlüssel zu sein für die Lösung der Probleme, die sich abzeichneten und die damals wenige Denker im Prinzip schon gesehen haben oder zumindest haben sehen wollen. Ich denke, es hat auch häufig einfach was damit zu tun, dass man auch selber bereit ist, das auch anzunehmen. Ich meine, Nachrichten und Informationen haben wir genug, aber das eigene Verhalten zu ändern oder sogar andere dazu zu bringen, ihr Verhalten zu ändern, erfordert natürlich auch so eine gewisse Ehrlichkeit zu sich selber, die man vielleicht nicht immer ohne weiteres aufbringt.
Zu haben oder nicht zu haben?
Doch, Eitelkeit habe ich, ohne Ende sozusagen. Verstehen Sie, darum bin ich ja dieser heutigen Selfiegeneration so nahe. Also die Leute, die sich ständig angrinsen und sagen, was bin ich für ein toller Hecht, inzwischen ist Anerkennung in den sozialen Netzwerken so viel wichtiger als Geld geworden. Und das ist toll, weil dadurch setzt sich auch Cradle to Cradle viel schneller um, weil die Leute wollen kein Idiot sein. Das reicht schon aus, verstehen Sie? Wenn Sie nur nicht doof sein wollen, die ich bin doch nicht blöde Generation kommt jetzt an der Universität an, und das reicht völlig. Jemand der Kunststoff macht was nachher in Robben und Schildkröten sich findet ist einfach nur ein Idiot, verstehen Sie? Und das reicht aus, ich brauche nur ein bisschen Eitelkeit. Ich bin nur einfach wirklich ein viel besserer Chemiker, als dass wenn Sie Chemikalien machen. Ich untersuche seit 27 Jahren Muttermilchproben. Es gibt keine, die man als Trinkmilch vermarkten dürfte. Dann sind Sie doch ein Idiot, also ich kann nicht so doof sein, Chemikalien zu machen, die nachher das Baby aufnimmt davon.
Und Chemikalien die unfruchtbar machen, PVC-Weichmacher zum Beispiel, Sie sind umgeben von Deppen sozusagen. Und darum reicht es völlig, kein Depp sein zu wollen. Also wenn Sie einen Parkschein anfassen, dann nehmen Sie dutzende Chemikalien auf, die ich Ihnen nachher in Muttermilch überall zeigen kann. Wenn Sie nur den Euro anfassen, nehmen Sie zweihundert mal mehr Nickel auf, als es legal ist für jeden anderen Gegenstand. Das ist so was von .... die Leute machen diese 3D-Drucker und hauen die sich zu Hause hin mit den übelsten Stinkdingern davon und denken nur, es sieht nett aus. Ja ein nettes Stöffchen sozusagen, ohne irgendwie zu reflektieren, was das wirklich ist. Oder Laserdrucker, mit jeder Seite die Sie drucken haben Sie zwischen 6 und 8 Milliarden Feinststaubteile, die nachher Ihre ganzen Zellen durchbohren und dann machen Sie auch Homeoffice und stellen sich so ein blödes Ding dort hin. Verstehen Sie, Eitelkeit reicht völlig aus, also nur kein Idiot sein zu wollen und das ist viel stabiler.
Weil die Moral ist auch bei mir weg, wenn ich im Stress bin. Wenn ich zum Beispiel auf der Autobahn bin und zu spät dran bin, dann bin ich auch verleitet, die Spur zu wechseln, obwohl ich genau weiß, dass ich für die Leute hinter mir im Durchschnitt zweihundert mal mehr Verzögerung verursache, wie ich selber an Zeit gewinnen kann. Ist mir aber im Moment egal, ich habe es ja eilig. Am schlimmsten rasen die Leute in Rotterdam vor Kindergärten. Weil unsere Kinder sind für das Industriesystem nicht gemacht, und wir liefern die ab und dann rasen die davon. Die fahren im Durchschnitt doppelt so schnell wie es erlaubt ist. Kümmern sich einen Dreck, dass die kleinen Kinder unterwegs sind. Darum keine moralgebundenen Systeme, die funktionieren nur für Mutter Teresa. Aber für normale Leute wie Sie und mich ist die Moral immer dann weg, wenn man sie eigentlich haben müsste.
Das heißt Sie haben eigentlich mehr einen sportlichen Antrieb, das zu tun was Sie tun?
Nein, das ist Eitelkeit. Ich möchte in der Tat in spätestens 10 Jahren den Chemienobelpreis haben für Chemie. Weil die jetzige Chemie einfach so primitiv ist und ich Chemie kann, die völlig anders ist und die wirklich einfach die ganze Materialwissenschaft nochmal neu erfindet.
Ich würde das jetzt mal durchaus mit Sport vergleichen können, weil die wollen ja auch alle die Goldmedaille haben.
Naja wie man es nimmt. Als ich 15 Jahre alt war, konnte ich 1,95m hoch springen, aber wie gesagt, was hab ich davon, wenn ich jetzt noch 20cm höher springen kann dabei und ich habe es dann bleiben lassen und insoweit also eine Goldmedaille wäre nicht mein Ziel.
Aber die Nobelmedaille alleine dürfte es ja wahrscheinlich auch nicht sein, sondern es ist ja auch schon sozusagen der Wunsch, eine Veränderung auch zu bewirken, die nachhaltig ist.
Nein, nichts mit Nachhaltigkeit. Nachhaltigkeit ist doch wirklich langweilig. Mir geht es allein um Qualität. Ein Produkt was Abfall wird ist einfach nur ein schlechtes Produkt. Und wenn ich irgendwo auf meine Arbeit stolz sein will, dann bin ich kein Idiot, das ist alles.
Gut, daraus haben Sie dann vor einiger Zeit, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht ganz genau, wann ist dieses Buch erschienen von Ihnen Cradle to Cradle? Wann war das?
Eigentlich ist es, also das Projekt Cradle to Cradle kam zustande durch die schweizerische Chemieindustrie nach der Sandoz-Katastrophe, dort war der ganze Fluss rosa gefärbt und die Fische kamen alle um. Und die schweizer Chemieindustrie fragte sich, wie sie weiter umgehen sollte. Die meisten haben ihre Namen geändert und haben gesagt, wir machen keine Chemie mehr, wir machen Life-Science, Novatis, Aventis. Alle Kunstnamen und sozusagen, wir sind jetzt keine Chemie mehr, nein nein Life-Science. Oder Pharma, ja Pharma ist doch für die Menschheit sozusagen auch gut. Und ein paar sind halt nachdenklich geworden. Und die haben mich damals beauftragt dann und haben gesagt, hier wir stellen Ihnen viel Geld zur Verfügung.
Wann war das in etwa?
Ja das war nach der Sandoz-Katastrophe, 86 war die, und 88 kamen sie zu mir und haben gesagt, ich sagte, kein Problem kann durch dieselbe Denkweise gelöst werden, die es verursacht hat, nach Albert Einstein. Wenn ihr nur das bestehend weitermacht, macht ihr das Flasche perfekt. Die DDR hat letztlich die Umwelt besser geschützt durch Ineffizienz als der Westen, weil sie das Geld nicht hatten, die Feuchtgebiete zu zerstören. Das heißt es ist erst mal die Frage, zu fragen, was ist das richtige. Also effektiv zu sein. Und dann haben sie mir viel Geld gegeben und ich konnte mir den Dalai Lama lange anhören. Ich konnte Michal Gorbatschow befragen, ich konnte ganz viele Leute, vor allem viele Naturvölker mir anschauen und fragen, wie ist deren Verhältnis zur Natur, was kann man daraus lernen? Also in China zum Beispiel, wenn man auf dem Land zum Essen eingeladen ist, dann erwarten die Leute heute noch, dass man solange bleibt, bis man die Toilette aufgesucht hat. Es gilt als unhöflich zu gehen und die Nährstoffe mitzunehmen, weil man ist ja zum Essen eingeladen worden.
Also Cradle to Cradle verbindet die europäische Gründlichkeit und Problemorientierung, allerdings mit den Nachteilen, wir forschen immer und tun eigentlich nichts dabei. Solange geforscht wird gibt es ja Forschungsgeld und niemand muss was tun. Mit der amerikanischen Handlungsorientierung, also Dinge zu tun, allerdings führt das in Amerika immer dann zu Aktivitäten, die vielleicht nicht problemgerecht sind, weil man das Problem gar nicht verstanden hat. Es gibt in den USA nur Forschung, von A nach B zu kommen, aber nicht von A nach T nach M nach P und dann B, da zahlt niemand etwas dafür. Drum kommt die Innovation nach wie vor aus Europa, aber umgesetzt wird sie in den USA. Die Glühbirne hat nicht Eddison erfunden, sondern irgendein schwäbischer Landpastor sozusagen. Der Computer wurde auch nicht von IBM erfunden. Nein von Menschen hier in Deutschland dazu. Und das Auto wurde auch nicht von Herrn Ford erfunden, aber die Umsetzung in Massenproduktionen und die Effizienzsteigerung das können die Amerikaner besser als jemand sonst.
Dann braucht es aber vor allem das asiatischen Denken in Kreisläufen. Unser Denken ist linear, von der Wiege zur Bahre, nicht von der Wiege zur Wiege. Und es braucht die südliche Lebensfreude. Ich meine, einfach einen Kirschbaum anzugucken und nicht zu sagen, oh verdammt diese unnützen Blüten, könnt ihr nicht weniger Blüten machen? Nein, es geht um intelligente Verschwendung, die Natur ist großzügig und verschwenderisch, wenn sie genügend Energie hat. Und wir haben mehr als genug Energie auf dem Planeten.
Der Begriff Cradle to Cradle, also von der Wiege zur Wiege, ist quasi so eine Umbiegung des Begriffs von der Wiege bis zur Bahre, dass alles was irgendwie anfängt dann halt irgendwann mal komplett zu Ende ist. Sprich Cradle to Cradle atmet so diesen Geist von das was einmal geworden ist ist in seinem Endstadium die Wiege des neuen?
Nein nein, es gibt ja gar kein Endstadium, von Vornherein nicht. Das ist das ewige Leben sozusagen. Also wir schaffen sozusagen, wenn wir es schon für uns selber nicht hinkriegen, darin sicher zu sein, dass wir ewig leben, unsere Gegenstände auf die wir Leben projizieren. Die Leute machen immer diese albernen Lebenszyklus analysieren für Colaflaschen, ich habe noch nie eine lebende Colaflasche gesehen. Aber wenn wir das schon projizieren, dann heißt das wirklich, zu sagen, alles ist Nährstoff. Und zwar auch noch nicht mal Kreislauf. Wenn die sagen, ja das geht in Kreisläufen. Nein, das ist blöde, ich will ja nicht immer wieder als Meerschweinchen auf die Welt kommen sozusagen, sondern alles ist Nährstoff. Die Dinge, die verschleißen, die kaputt gehen durch ihre Anwendung sich ändern, Schuhsohlen, Bremsbeläge, Autoreifen, Waschmittel, die also wirklich sich chemisch, physikalisch, biologisch ändern, werden nützlich für die Biosphäre. So wie ein Kirschbaum im Frühling nützlich ist, nicht weniger schädlich, alle Dinge, die nur genutzt werden, so wie Waschmaschinen, so wie Fernsehen, Mobiltelefone, die werden nützlich für die Technosphäre.
Also es gibt eine Technosphäre und eine Biosphäre. Es gibt also keinen Abfall mehr. Aber auch nicht eine Welt ohne Abfall, wie die Leute dann schreiben. Weil dann denken sie immer noch an Abfall. Und wenn ich sage, denken Sie nicht an ein rosarotes Krokodil, dann denken Sie an ein rosarotes Krokodil. Nein für mich ist alles Nährstoff für die Biosphäre und die Technosphäre. Weil wir eben nicht nur wie Ameisen leben wollen, sondern eben Computer und Waschmaschinen auch haben wollen, gibt es eben neben der Biosphäre eben auch die Technosphäre.
Schließt denn so ein Denken bestimmte Produktkategorien, die wir heute gewohnt sind, aus? Oder denken Sie, dass sich dieses Modell durchaus auf alles was wir heute haben erweitern lässt?
Ja wenn Sie fragen, schließt das Modell, dass die Erde rund ist, dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist, dann schließt das aus, dass die Erde eine Scheibe ist. Natürlich gibt es bei Cradle to Cradle keine Müllverbrennungsanlagen, weil es ja keinen Müll gibt. Es gibt auch keine Deponien, weil es ja keinen Müll gibt.
Ja gut, jetzt aber Müllverbrennungsanlagen und Deponien sind ja nicht die Art von Produkten, die ich gemeint habe.
Ja aber ein Sigmar Gabriel stellt sich hin und sagt, es kann niemand so gründlich zerstören wie wir Deutsche, wir liefern überall Müllverbrennungsanlagen als Entwicklungshilfe. Selbst Shanghei hat eine deutsche Müllverbrennungsanlage geschenkt bekommen, für Müll der gar nicht brennt. Die müssen am Tag 60 Tonnen Heizöl dazu geben, das gilt dann als Umwelttechnik, verstehen Sie? Solche Umwelttechnikprodukte fallen alle weg. Wenn Sie die Filter am Anfang ins Denken packen, dann brauchen Sie keine Filter am Ende. Sie brauchen dann keine Kläranlage sozusagen, die dann giftige Stoffe heraussucht. Also diese Sachen fallen weg.
Nehmen wir mal so ein einfaches Beispiel. Das Auto ist ein zumindest heute hochkomplexes Produkt, je nachdem wie man das so betrachtet, aber sehr viele Stoffe da drin, Lacke, Stähle, Kunststoffe ohne Ende. Ein hoher Ressourcenbedarf in jeder Hinsicht, jetzt mal von der Energie, die dafür benötigt wird, das herzustellen mal ganz abgesehen. Wie könnten Sie sich das vorstellen, dass so etwas wie ein Auto wirklich vollständig wieder in einen Kreislauf zurückgeführt wird oder in ein fortwährendes Neuentstehen, was sind da die Herausforderungen, die noch nicht gelöst sind?
Na nehmen Sie zum Beispiel einen Fernseher. Wenn jemand einen Fernseher kauft, kauft er im Moment 4360 verschiedene Chemikalien. Will der wirklich 4360 Chemikalien haben oder möchte er fernsehen? Ein Auto, möchte wirklich jemand ein Auto haben oder möchte jemand Mobilität haben? Das heißt jetzt geht die Branche noch hin und versucht, den Verbrennungsmotor durch einen Elektromotor zu ersetzen, das heißt das Falsche praktisch zu perfektionieren an der Stelle. Weil bei der jetzigen Form von Transport sind über die Hälfte der Menschen ausgeschlossen. Kinder und Alte und Kranke, davon sind alle nicht dabei. Das ist nur für die Hälfte der Bevölkerung ein Mobilitätskonzept. Trotzdem Autos können durchaus eine Rolle spielen, aber die müssten ganz anders aussehen. Es fängt damit an, dass wir jetzt überall diese Leichenhäuser für Autos haben sozusagen, wo wir überall diese Autos zwischenlagern, weil sie ja nur an einer Stunde täglich wirklich verwendet werden und 23 Stunden rumstehen. Man könnte ja zum Beispiel diese Parkhäuser nutzen, um Nachtmärkte zu machen.
Weil selbst in einer Innenstadt wie Hamburg sind die Parkplätze nur zu 12% wirklich die Parkplätze besetzt. Die Fläche daraus ist unter 5%, die wirklich mit Autos besetzt ist im Durchschnitt auf die Jahreszeit hin.
Sie meinen jetzt alle Plätze an den Straßen oder in den Parkhäusern?
Nein, in den Parkhäusern. Die Parkhäuser zunächst mal. Das ist ja völlig albern, weil dann ist also nur 12% der Stellfläche der Autos ist besetzt davon. Von der Gesamtfläche ist es noch viel weniger, weil ja das Auto noch Transport- und Wegeflächen dazwischen braucht. Warum machen wir nicht Nachtmärkte oder warum machen wir nicht temporäre Minigolfplätze oder warum machen wir nicht Wohnmöglichkeiten sozusagen, immer dann wenn das Auto dort nicht den Platz braucht. Aber es fängt mit ganz vielen Dingen an. Ich will da nur bruchstückmäßig zeigen, nur jetzt den Elektromotor als Elektromobilität zu machen ist relativ albern. Es kuriert nur am Symptom. Wir haben zum Beispiel ja ursprünglich den Smart mal uns völlig anders gedacht mit Herrn Hayek in den 80er Jahren. Wir wollten ein Auto haben, und von Vornherein nur 100.000 km verkauft. Da sollte alles drin sein. Es gibt jetzt Schmieröle, die man nicht austauschen muss.
Dann wird das zwar viel teurer, aber sparen im Betrieb so viel ein. Oder es gibt Reifen, deren Rollwiderstand so viel geringer ist. Der Hersteller hat davon nichts, wenn ein energiesparendes Auto entsteht. Aber wenn er nur den Kilometer verkauft inklusive des Treibstoffs, dann lohnt es sich, ein benzin- oder treibstoffsparendes Auto überhaupt zu haben. Da ist die Wartung drin, dann lohnt es sich ein wartungsarmes Auto zu haben. Dann ist die Reparatur drin, dann ist die Reparatur einfacher. Nach fünf Jahren geht das Auto in ein Enzymbad und die Klebstoffe werden aufgefressen und die Komponenten können wieder eingesetzt werden. Wenn Sie auf das Rohmaterial zurückgehen, haben Sie nur 5% der Wertschöpfung. In einem Handy sind an Materialien nicht mehr als 1,50 EUR an Wert drin, aber die Komponenten sind wertvoll. Dann können Sie die Komponenten wieder gewinnen und wieder neu einsetzen dabei. Das heißt Sie bezahlen monatlich nur für die Nutzung dieses Autos. Das war Mitte der 80er Jahre als Student habe ich das vorgeschlagen und damals wurde ich als Ökokommunist beschimpft.
Weil das Eigentum war halt über Religion ... und was habe ich als einziges durchgesetzt bekommen? Das war das Cockpit im Smart. Da ist der Stoff draufgewschweißt, das sind 13,8kg Polypropylen, reines Polypropylen zurückzugewinnen. Das ist alles. Solche Dinge brauchen Zeit, aber Sie müssen sehen, das erste Internet war 1973. Das erste Mobiltelefon war 1967. Dafür ist Cradle to Cradle wahnsinnig gut im Zeitplan jetzt. Die europäische Union hat jetzt erklärt, dass sie Cradle to Cradle zur Basis machen will. Es gab eine große Ankündigung. Sie nennen das dann noch ein bisschen Circular Economy, was natürlich blöde ist, das ist 1962 haben wir zum ersten Mal in Deutschland Veröffentlichungen zu Kreislaufwirtschaft gehabt. Nein es geht nicht um Kreislaufwirtschaft. Das ist lineares Denken im Kreis, das meine ich damit nicht. Aber Sie müssen ja auch sehen, dass viele Länder wie Großbritannien nie eine echte Umweltdiskussion hatten.
Das heißt die fangen jetzt mit Dingen an, die bei uns in den 70er Jahren in Deutschland diskutiert worden sind. Mit Plastiktüten und solchem Zeug halt. Und das ist sehr ungleichzeitig davon. Es setzt sich mit einer wahnsinnigen Geschwindigkeit durch. Es gibt inzwischen viele tausend Cradle to Cradle Produkte auf dem Markt.
Ich will nochmal kurz bei dem Auto bleiben. Nur um das mal an einem Beispiel auch wirklich greifbar zu machen. Also ein Auto, das dann nach 100.000 Kilometern zurückgegeben wird und in einem – habe ich das richtig verstanden – in einem Enzymbad aufgelöst wird?
Ja klar, die Enzyme...
Vollständig?
Nein, die Klebstoffe werden aufgelöst. Weil Klebeverbindungen können wenn sie richtig gemacht sind viel stabiler sein als Schweißverbindungen. Und sie erlauben mir dann, dass ich den Werkstoff passgenau wieder zurück kriege. Wenn ich es zusammenschrauben muss oder schweißen, dann kriege ich es ja nicht wieder wirklich passgenau auseinander. Dann kann ich die Komponenten einsetzen daraus, wie ein Legoauto praktisch. Die Klebstoffe können damit reversibel sein. Also ich kann sie wieder auflösen, nach 24 Stunden kann ich aus dem Enzymbad die Komponenten abfiltrieren und dann wieder neu einsetzen für unterschiedliche Zwecke. Das heißt definierter Nutzungs???
Was heißt jetzt Komponenten? Also wir reden nicht vom Kotflügel, sondern wir reden schon von einer chemischen?
Ja wir reden durchaus von Teilen für den Unterboden zum Beispiel. Also wo wir dann ganze Elemente sozusagen verwenden können davon. Also ganze Baugruppen. Die müssen natürlich anders konstruiert sein als es im Augenblick so ist. Also denken Sie viel eher sozusagen an ein Legoauto, dann verstehen Sie, dass Sie die verschiedenen Dinge mit Klebstoffen zusammensetzen können und auch wieder auseinandernehmen können.
Ja gut, aber wenn ich mir jetzt so einen Innovationszyklus im Autodesign vorstelle und man würde jetzt nach weiß nicht wie viele Jahre man jetzt für diese 100.000 Kilometer gebraucht hat, die selben Teile, die ich vor 4-5 Jahren verbaut habe wiederholen, dann ist doch unter Umständen die Innovation schon weiter und das erste Teil ist als solches gar nicht mehr verwendbar.
Aber nicht in der Form.
Nein, als Komponente aber natürlich.
Als chemische Komponente.
Nein nicht nur als chemische Komponente. Also zum Beispiel kann ich durchaus Bausteine so konstruieren, dass ich sie dann zusammenstelle. Dazu einen Lufteinlass zum Beispiel kann so konstruiert sein, dass er dann durchaus Träger werden kann für Elektronikinformation in einer Waschmaschine drin. Ein Fensterprofil, davon kann durchaus als Profil für Gewächshäuser zum Beispiel konstruiert werden. Das heißt wir nennen das Materials Pooling. Es ist uns zum Beispiel gelungen, die Firma Lego mit der Firma Philips zusammen zu kriegen, dann konnten die gemeinsam die Materialien verwenden. Dadurch wird es viel billiger, weil Lego dadurch den Kunststoff viel billiger einkaufen kann und Philips bekommt einen viel sauberen Kunststoff. Also das sind völlig neue Strategien, die nicht nur einfach mechanistisch das eine Material wieder hier rein packen und darüber anders. Sondern natürlich bedeutet das, dass man Elektromotoren zum Beispiel überlegt, wie sie eingesetzt werden können und anders dimensioniert.
Dass sie zum Beispiel heute halt in einem Auto verwendet werden, morgen in Förderbändern zum Beispiel an Flughäfen eingesetzt werden können. Dafür müssen sie aber gedacht werden. Darum ein Design for Reincarnation, also das nächste Leben sozusagen von Vornherein mit eingeplant. Und dann bekomme ich viel vielfältigere und schönere Dinge daraus, weil ich nicht mehr die billigsten Dinge verwenden muss. Das bedeutet zum Beispiel in einer Miele-Waschmaschine sind etwa 150 verschiedene billige stinkige Kunststoffe drin, ich kann diese Waschmaschine mit drei Kunststoffen herstellen. Und diese Kunststoffe lassen sich universell einsetzen. Und wenn ich es jetzt dann in Komponenten bringe, die ich auch für andere Komponenten einsetzen kann, dann spare ich natürlich ganz vieles zusätzlich an Aufwand. Aber Sie haben recht, bei Kunststoffen ist natürlich dann eher das Umschmelzen und die Neueinsetzung auf das Material zurückgehen. Aber auch auf ein sauberes Material und nicht auf eine Parkbank und eine Lärmschutzwand.
Also die Polysulfone zum Beispiel von der BRSF???, das sind Kunststoffe, die können sie endlos einsetzen. Also hunderte Mal können Sie die einschmelzen.
Wie heißen die?
Polysulfone, das ist kondensierte Sulfonsäure sozusagen und die sind formstabil, die sind inhärent flammengeschützt. Finden im Moment praktisch keinen Markt, weil sie etwa doppelt so teuer sind, wie die anderen Massenkunststoffe dabei. Wenn ich sie aber als Dienstleistung verwende und die Firma BRSF von Vornherein nur sagt, wir sind die Materialbank für Polysulfone, dann würde die Anwendung endlos möglich sein damit.
Sind Kunststoffe nicht in gewisser Hinsicht auch so das Hauptproblem derzeit in unserer Verbrauchskultur?
Nein.
Wir hatten ja vorhin auch schon die Belastung der Meere herangeführt, das ist ja im Wesentlichen eine Belastung durch Kunststoffe.
Nein, neinneinnein, die sind sozusagen am direktesten sichtbar. Also der primitivste Umgang mit ??? allen Dingen ist immer noch der mit Metallen. Metalle zum Beispiel so eine Becks-Bierdose wird beschichtet mit einem Pigment, was ein Recycling praktisch ausschließt. Da ist Kupfer drin und da ist Chlor drin und das braucht zu viel Energie.
???
Nein also das Grün von Carlsberg oder von Becks oder von Heineken, das Grün die Flaschenfarbe ist sozusagen, das Grün ist sozusagen das giftigste von den Pigmenten, die wir überhaupt kennen. Und weil dann das Aluminium zum Beispiel angeschmolzen wird, ist es immer minderwertig nur allein durch das Pigment schon was drauf ist. Also die Kombination Metallbeschichtung ist was Umwelt angeht extrem primitiv. Wie gesagt, wenn Sie 46 Legierungen machen, um einen BMW herzustellen und dann nachher machen Sie draus Baustahl, dann ist das die Bankrotterklärung überhaupt. Sie sehen, es gibt in Hamburg eine Kupferhütte, wenn die eine Millionen Tonnen Kupfer erzeugt, dann verursacht sie, wenn sie neues Kupfer herstellt, etwa dreimal mehr Müll als das gesamte europäische Müllaufkommen.
Das heißt wenn das Kupfer nicht als technischer Nährstoff wirklich begriffen wird, zum Beispiel zwischengelagert wird in Windräder für 20 Jahre Nutzungskupfer, und im Moment war die Kupferrecyclingrate noch nie so gering, das reichert sich im Baustahl an und führt bei Erdbeben wie in der Türkei zu völlig unnötigen Todesfällen, weil bei Kupfergehalten über 0,5% bricht der Stahl wie ein Osteoporoseknochen. Wenn Sie also Metalle so primitiv behandeln, die eigentlich endlos einsetzbar wären perse, dann ist die erste Baustelle der Umgang mit Metallen. Weil die Leute gucken ja immer nur den Hausmüll an, aber wie gesagt, bei einer Tonne Kupfer entstehen bei der Neuproduktion zwischen 600 und 800 Tonnen an Sonderabfall, bei einer einzigen Tonne. Da ist wie gesagt das Hausmüllaufkommen völlig irrelevant im Verhältnis zu der Müllmenge, die entsteht, bei dem nichtadäquaten Umgehen mit den Materialien vorher.
Das heißt der wichtigste und größte Hebel ist zunächst einmal die industrielle Produktion?
Der wichtigste Hebel ist die Intelligenz am Anfang. Die Frage ist eine soziale und kulturelle Frage. Für weniger schädlich sind wir viel zu viele Menschen auf der Welt. Wenn wir lernen, die Menschen als Chance zu begreifen, dann könnten wir auch 30 Milliarden Menschen sein. Denn wenn man die Existenz von Menschen in Frage stellt, wenn man sagt, es wäre besser, du wärst gar nicht da, dann werden die Menschen raffgieriger und feindselig. Weil sie dann sagen, bevor du es mir wegnimmst, raff ich es doch lieber an mich. Drum gibt es im Moment jetzt hunderte und tausende von Materialbanken, wo die Leute einfach Metalle zwischenlagern, weil sie Angst haben, die Währung könnte ja irgendwie ihren Wert verlieren dabei. Oder sie kaufen wie die Irren irgendwelche Eigentumswohnungen in Berlin für 5000 Euro den Quadratmeter, eine Schrottimmobilie in Kreuzberg oder so was, weil sie Angst haben. Aus Angst werden die Menschen raffgierig und feindselig. Wenn Menschen sich sicher fühlen, wenn sie ihre Identität haben, wenn sie keine Angst, dann sind sie immer großzügiger und freundlich, sie geben immer ab an die anderen.
Das heißt wir verursachen sozusagen durch diese, Al Gore sagt Überbevölkerung, die wir verursachen das Problem erst dadurch, dass wir die Menschen zum Feind erklären, denn dadurch werden sie so. Wenn Sie ein Kind in die Ecke stellen und sagen, du bist verhaltensgestört, nach drei Tagen spätestens ist es verhaltensgestört.
Ich wollte jetzt noch ein bisschen mal darauf hinaus, wo man ansetzen kann. Vor allem wenn man sich jetzt als junger Wissenschaftler, junge Wissenschaftlerin fragt, wie stell ich mich ein auf diese Welt, wie verstehe ich mein eigenes Wirken und wie kann ich mich jetzt hier auch vielleicht mit dieser Idee am meisten einbringen? Weil es birgt ja auf jeden Fall eine ganze Menge Potenzial. Also hier scheint es einfach noch sehr viel Lösungsansätze zu geben, die man neu verfolgen und neu erdenken kann. Was ist so der Hebel, den man suchen sollte? Ist es zunächst einmal die Forschung, dass man überhaupt erst mal auf Lösungen kommt oder muss man erst mal sich die richtige Psychologie zulegen, um Leute zu überzeugen von dieser Idee?
Nein, ich glaube, wir können jetzt zeigen, dass wir 40 Jahre Weltuntergangsdiskussion in Innovation und Qualität umsetzen können. Und ich bin auch deshalb ??? in die USA zurückgegangen, weil in den USA denken die Leute, die sagen Wirtschaftswachstum, wenn sie mehr in China einkaufen. Wir haben für viele Bereiche eine funktionierende industrielle Basis, aber es wird jetzt die Zeit dafür knapp, weil wir haben versucht, ein bisschen weniger schädlich zu sein und verursachen ganz viele Kosten. Wenn Sie eine Solaranlage kaufen, dann haben Sie den Müll am Hals. Wenn Sie aber nur 20 Jahre Photonen einfangen kaufen???, dann lohnt es sich, eine Anlage zu machen, die auch in Europa gefertigt wird und repariert werden kann. Wenn Sie Druckerzeugnisse machen, die kompostierbar sind, dann konkurrieren Sie nicht mehr mit Sklavenarbeit aus Malaysia. Das heißt wir sind auf halbem Wege stecken geblieben. Und in Gefahr und großer Not ist der Mittelweg der Tod. Wir machen jetzt in unseren Pizzakartons das Recycling für chinesischen Sondermüll, weil es sich lohnt, jetzt die Kataloge am nächsten Tag 40% billiger in Frankfurt einzufliegen und machen damit das Recycling und sagen, der Standort ist zu teuer.
Jetzt weil wir denken, das ist ein Moralthema. Die Frage ist, es ist eine reine Innovationsfrage. Qualität, Innovation, vielleicht noch Schönheit, wenn man es romantisch ausdrücken will. Ein Produkt, was einen krank macht ist einfach nicht schön. Und ich gehe im Moment in Holland von Gymnasium zu Gymnasium und lade die Abiturienten ein und stelle ihnen das vor was ich mache und von 400 Abiturienten sind mindestens 30, die sofort sagen, da will ich mitmachen. Wir brauchen jetzt die besten Leute, die Physik und Chemie und Biologie und Ingenieurwissenschaften studieren und nicht die Opportunisten, die sagen, ich habe da noch eine sichere Stelle für eine bestimmte Zeit. Das heißt wir brauchen jetzt vor allem halt Leute, die nicht das Bestehende nur optimieren, sie können auch mit begrenzter Intelligenz das Bestehende optimieren. Weil Sie nur sagen, okay das soll jetzt 10% leichter sein. Aber zu fragen, was das richtige ist, braucht völlig andere wissenschaftliche Herangehensweise, wo wirklich verschiedene Fachrichtungen zusammenarbeiten.
Also eben nicht Effizienz, etwas richtig zu machen, sondern zu fragen, was ist das Richtige. Was ist gesunde Ernährung, was ist gesundes Wohnen? Die Luftqualität hier im Gebäude ist etwa 3-8 mal schlechter als schlechte städtische Außenluft. Wenn ich das Gebäude jetzt noch versiegele und gasdicht mache, dann mache ich das Flasche nur perfekt. Anstatt zuerst mal zu sagen, was ist gesunde Luft? Asthma ist häufigste Kinderkrankheit. Aber Sie können es ganz simpel sehen, wir haben so viele frustrierte naturwissenschaftliche Lehrer deshalb ja auch. Von 1000 Studenten, die ich treffe, wirklich von 1000 und ich habe jetzt das etwa mit 40000 insgesamt aus der Welt ausprobiert, weiß nur ein einziger, was das Zentralatom in der wichtigsten Chemiesynthese des Planeten ist. Im Chlorophyll die Photosynthese. Wirklich nur ein einziger weiß was in diesem drin ist.
Ist ja die gleiche Struktur wie beim Blutfarbstoff. Im Blutfarbstoff weiß man, es ist Eisen. Aber das Zentralatom in der wichtigsten Chemiesynthese der Welt überhaupt ist nicht bekannt. Das heißt, obwohl es für uns wichtig ist für die Ernährung auch, also wir haben alle nicht mal die Hälfte der notwendigen Magnesiummenge, die wir aufnehmen. Wissen wir nicht, dass das Magnesium im Chlorophyll drin ist. Wirklich nur einer von 1000. Unsere naturwissenschaftliche Ausbildung ist so stümperhaft ganz am Anfang davon. Darum ist es so schön, es gibt jetzt zum Beispiel, es gab einen Herrn Konrad Hall, der hat sich von mir einen Vortrag angehört in Stuttgart und hat gesagt, ich setz das um. Und der hat ein Museum für Kinder gemacht, was Cradle to Cradle, innerhalb eines Jahres in Donau-Ischingen es umgesetzt, ein Cradle to Cradle Museum für Kinder und Jugendliche, wie die Zukunft aussehen kann. Ein echtes Museum für die Zukunft, unterstützt von der Baden-Württemberg Stiftung und von Bosch und allen möglichen, in Aesculab und also vielen Firmen.
Weil wir brauchen jetzt Kinder, die staunen und nicht sagen, oh verdammt Naturwissenschaft oder Ingenieurwissenschaft. Wir brauchen die Neugierde von jungen Leuten, die einfach sagen, warum nicht anders, warum müssen wir das Bestehende einfach nur ein bisschen weniger schlecht machen und denken, das sei Umweltschutz, das ist keiner.
Ich meine, das Problem haben natürlich die Wissenschaften schon länger und immer wieder. Manche Disziplinen häufiger, manche seltener. Chemie hatten wir schon, hat auf jeden Fall eine sehr schlechte Phase gehabt so in den letzten Jahrzehnten, was sich jetzt vielleicht langsam wieder bessert.
Im Moment noch nicht.
Heißt das nicht, dass man im Prinzip schon an der Bildung, also auch an der schulischen Bildung ansetzen muss?
Ja natürlich, im Kindergarten eigentlich schon. Darum ist dieses Museum in Donau-Ischingen so interessant, weil man da sehen kann, wie da wirklich tausende von jungen Kindern einfach mit größter Begeisterung lernen und zwar ohne, dass es ihnen jemand vorschreibt, sondern weil das Design des Lernens so ist, dass sie das können damit. Und natürlich fehlen auch die entsprechenden Rechnerprogramme. Ich meine, warum machen wir so viele dümmliche Computerspiele sozusagen, wo wir Inhalte völlig anders vermitteln könnten. Aber ich meine es hat mehrere solche Technikbrüche gegeben. Wenn Sie sehen, mit welcher Begeisterung die Leute vor dem ersten Weltkrieg an Technik dran waren. Das war wirklich faszinierend. Aber dann haben sie gesehen, dass die Technik verwendet wird, um Menschen gegenseitig zu vergiften und zu ermorden und das hat einen totalen Schock ausgelöst. Und dann eben solche Umweltkatastrophen, wie in Bhopal.
In Bhopal sind 500.000 Leute schlimm verletzt worden. Ich war dort gewesen. Sind 30.000 Menschen gestorben, die haben bis heute keinen Cent an Schadensersatz gekriegt. Und ich muss leider widersprechen, die Chemie ist nach wie vor nicht besser. Ich meine, wie gesagt, die 3D-Druckmaterialien sind so ziemlich das übelste, was Sie sich irgendwie vorstellen können. Das sind völlig moderne Produkte, eigentlich nie für Menschen gemacht. Die Laserdrucker genauso. Die Industrie verwendet auch zum Beispiel beim Papierdruck immer noch das was halt funktioniert. Seit der Entwicklung des Buchdrucks haben wir halt Cadmium und Chrom und Quecksilber genommen, weil es halt funktionierte. So wie Nina Hagen sagen würde, weil es so schön bunt ist. Und jetzt wissen wir, dass es eigentlich anders geht, und anstatt dass wir jetzt sagen, in fünf Jahren wird Papier, was bedruckt wird, nur so bedruckt, dass es nachher kompostierbar ist, dann hätten wir eine Änderung. Darum braucht es eine gesellschaftliche Diskussion. Wenn wir sagen, in 10 Jahren ist die Luft in Gebäuden besser als schlechte städtische Außenluft, dann hätten meine jungen Ingenieure eine positive Aufgabe.
Das heißt wir müssen jetzt fragen, also positive Ziele geben davon und nicht zu sagen, bis 2020 möchte Hamburg 20% weniger CO2 abgeben. Das ist so kackegal eigentlich, ob die da weniger CO2 abgeben. Das wird in China in Sekunden ausgeglichen. Das ist nur Beschäftigungstherapie. Es entsteht jetzt eine Art Ökologismus, der gar nicht der Ökologie dient, aber nur die Menschen beschäftigt hält. Also in dem Kinderspielzeug von Matell sind mehrere hundert giftige Stoffe drin. Die EU verbietet anstatt 39 jetzt 64. Das ist Beschäftigungstherapie, so wie der Sozialismus nie sozial war, entsteht jetzt ein Ökologismus, der nicht der Ökologie dient, sondern uns nur beschäftigt hält. Also der ganze Maisanbau, wir verlieren dabei, wenn wir Biotreibstoffe machen, zwischen 11 und 40 Tonnen Boden pro Hektar und Jahr und der Boden ist der Kohlenstoffträger und nicht das Öl.
Warum ist das so? Also was sehen Sie als Ursache dafür, dass die Gesellschaft diesen Blickwinkel nicht einzunehmen bereit oder in der Lage ist?
Weil sie Angst hat. Sie ist angstgetrieben.
Ja, die ganzen Bilder, die die Menschen sehen, verursachen Ängeste. Sie speichern die. Jede Katastrophe, diese ganzen vielen Bilder überfordern die Menschen, weil ja ein einziges Bild eines zusammengestürzten Hochhauses beim Erdbeben in Chile ist so viel Information, wie drei mal Goethes Faust sozusagen. Was sie da einfach aufnehmen durch das Sehen praktisch, das blockiert sie sozusagen, weil sie dann Angst haben, dass ihnen das und das passieren könnte selber. Und die erste Sache ist wirklich, zu sagen, Leute habt keine Angst. Wir wissen jetzt aus diesen 40 Jahren, wie wir alle Dinge nochmal neu erfinden können. Und dann kann jeder dazu beitragen. Aber nicht, die bestehenden Dinge zu optimieren. Wir verwenden 3 Millionen Tonnen Palmenöl aus Indonesien und Malaysia als Biodiesel. Das ist ein Verbrechen.
Wovor? Vor Veränderung?
Weil ein Hektar Regenwald hat 7000 Tonnen Kohlenstoff, ein Hektar Palmenölplantage hat 60 Tonnen Kohlenstoff. Und dann diskutier ich mit Herrn Baroso, dem damaligen Kommissionspräsidenten, der sagt, Herr Braungart wir werden jetzt nur noch zertifiziertes Palmenöl nehmen. Das heißt wir lassen die Chinesen abholzen, weil die älteren Plantagen sind auch ertragreicher. Anstatt zu sagen, Palmenöl ist für menschliche Ernährung und noch als Chemierohstoff wunderbar geeignet. Aber das ist es, weil das hat einfach als Treibstoff nichts zu suchen. Weil die Kohlenstoffbilanz ist völlig negativ dazu. Damit macht man nur das Falsche perfekt. Das passiert halt, weil die Leute kleine Segmente sehen. Weil sie einfach nicht sich wirklich den gesamten Bereich anschauen und fragen, wie wirkt sich das aus in den unterschiedlichen Bereichen?
Vor allem aber auch weil sie nicht bereit sind reversibel zu denken. Also zu sagen, wenn das falsch ist könnte ich es korrigieren. Wir schaffen damit Dinge, die praktisch wie bei der Atomenergie Belastungen für alle in der Zukunft sind. Wenn ich zum Beispiel hingehe und sage, ab morgen werden keine Chemikalien mehr hergestellt, die sich in Lebewesen anreichern. Chemical Haressment in Muttermilch, dann gäbe es eine Innovationsmöglichkeit ohne Ende. Stattdessen machen wir toxikologische Tests, ob jetzt diese Chemikalie mehr Krebs erzeugt oder die andere. Ich habe als Student ein Papier geschrieben über PVC-Weichmacher und ich zeige, dass sie unfruchtbar machen. Und die Industrie und die Wirtschaft und die Forschung hat nur bis letztes Jahr geforscht, ob auch das Meerschweinchen auch unfruchtbar wird oder die Schildkröte oder der Delfin oder sonst was. Lauter Dreck einfach, anstatt zu sagen, hey wenn es dafür berechtigte Sorge gibt, dann hören wir damit auf.
Stattdessen missbrauchen wir die Wissenschaft, um Dinge im Prinzip am Leben zu erhalten, wenn die Zigarettenindustrie nicht einmal die Ergebnisse eingeschlossen hätte im Panzerschrank, dann hätte sie nur sagen müssen, nein Rauchen verursacht nur Krebs, wenn man gleichzeitig Asbest aufnimmt und vielleicht in der Verwandtschaft eine türkische Großmutter hat und möglicherweise am Meer lebt und das müsste jetzt mehr untersucht werden, dann wären sie heute noch am forschen. Sie hat nur die dummen Fehler gemacht, die Ergebnisse in den Panzerschrank zu schließen. Damit war beweisbar, dass sie wusste, dass es Krebs erzeugt. Für alle anderen Dinge machen wir weiter. Sie kaufen einen VW, da steht drauf, original VW-Bremsbelag, frei von Asbest. Sie denken, das ist ja toll. Der Ersatz ist aber Antimonsulphit, das ist viel stärker krebserzeugend. Jetzt gibt es ein Forschungsprogramm, wie denn Antimonsulphit Krebs erzeugt, auch beim Meerschweinchen möglicherweise. Verstehen Sie? Das ist so was ein Missbrauch an wissenschaftlichen Werten.
An den Universitäten, wir forschen, um Probleme zu erhalten, anstatt wirklich Dinge zu lösen und darum verlieren natürlich auch die Universitäten gegenüber den Fachhochschulen ein Feld, weil die Industrie irgendwann für Produkte bezahlt wird und nicht für so zu tun als ob. Also wirklich nochmal ganz eine Reset-Taste drücken und sagen, lasst uns eine Welt planen für 10 Milliarden Menschen, wo alle genügend zu essen haben, das Leben genießen. Wir haben genügend Energie davon. Und dann kommen wir zu völlig anderen Antworten.
Ja aber wie machen wir das? Also ich meine, machen wir uns nichts vor, die Widerstände sind groß, was auch immer jetzt die Gründe sein mögen. Dummheit, Widerstände, zu viel lobbyistischer Einfluss von Besitzstandwahrern. Es gibt einfach eine ganze Menge Kräfte, und wenn man dem Ganzen jetzt nur mit einer wissenschaftlichen Logik kommt, die nachvollziehbar ist, zumindest für Wissenschaftler, ich denke die Erfahrung lehrt, dass das eben noch an sich jetzt erst mal kein Erfolgsrezept ist. Sondern man muss da wahrscheinlich auch noch andere Punkte setzen.
Ja hier setzt sich jetzt natürlich sehr schnell um. Es gibt jetzt zum Beispiel einen Cradle to Cradle Verein, einen Fernseher, den wir entwickelt haben mit Philips zusammen, wird nur übers Internet verkauft praktisch, weil es der erste Fernseher für Innenräume. Der gibt 30000 mal weniger Stoffe an die Umgebung ab, als die anderen Fernseher.
Also Sie meinen jetzt sozusagen, man muss einfach konkrete Produkte zeigen, die demonstrieren, dass dieser Weg möglich ist?
Nein, man soll nicht jammern davon. Ich habe nicht erwartet, dass sich Cradle to Cradle während meiner Lebzeit umsetzt, überhaupt nicht. Es hat zwischen der Erklärung der Menschenrechte und dem Frauenwahlrecht in Deutschland 150 Jahre gedauert. 150 Jahre haben die Leute gesagt, naja Frauen sind ja vielleicht doch keine Menschen. Oder sie sind nicht gescheit genug, dass sie vielleicht wählen sollten. Oder sie sind vielleicht zu emotional oder so was. Also für Dinge, die wirklich so bahnbrechend anders sind, dafür kommt dieses Cradle to Cradle so schnell voran, wo uns einfach das Internetzeitalter so in die Hände spielt, weil diese junge Selfiegeneration will einfach nur nicht doof sein. Für die jetzigen jungen Leute ist Anerkennung in ihrer sozialen Gruppe mindestens so wichtig wie Geld.
Aber man bekommt ja diese Anerkennung nicht unbedingt jetzt immer durch die Demonstration von Intelligenz und Verständnis der Dinge der Welt?
Nein, aber schauen Sie, Chemikalien zu machen – ich untersuche zum Beispiel Robben und Schildkröten mit Studenten, die verhungern mit vollem Magen mit Plastikabfall. Die Frage ist ja, ist die Kunststoffindustrie noch stark genug, sich die Lobby zu bezahlen, diese weiteren Studien zu machen, dass vielleicht die Schildkröten vielleicht doch gar nicht an Plastik verhungert sind, sondern vielleicht nur an irgendeinem Parasiten, der sie nicht mehr in die Lage brachte, diese Plastik zu erkennen, dass das keine Qualle ist, sondern eine Plastiktüte sozusagen. Oder ist er noch vital genug, jetzt wirklich umzusteuern. Das ist schon die Frage. Weil wir haben zum Beispiel 21 Jahre gearbeitet, ein Leder zu haben, was perfekt kompostierbar ist. Das wirklich eine Firma Leder mit Chrom herstellt, um dann eine Tierhaut zu stabilisieren, das ist doch absurd.
Da sind in einem Kilo Leder dann 40 Gramm Chrom enthalten. Wie absurd, 20% der Weltchromverwendung in die Ledergerbung, dass wir so doof sind, eine Tierhaut nur mit einem Schwermetall zu stabilisieren, das ist ja eine Bankrotterklärung. Jetzt gibt es ein neues Leder, aber es gibt praktisch keine große Gerberei mehr. Und die letzte Gerbereischule hat in Reutlingen geschlossen 2009. Jetzt wissen wir zwar wie es geht, aber wir werden nicht mehr die Vitalität haben, es umzusetzen. Weil denselben Dreck kann man in Malaysia oder in Marokko oder in Indien einfach billiger machen. Das heißt die Leute denken immer noch, das Umweltthema sei ein Moralthema und verstehen nicht, dass es die einzige europäische Innovationschance ist. Wirklich die allereinzige. Weil Rohstoffe können die anderen Leute billiger sich sichern an anderer Stelle. Wissenschaftler in anderen Stellen können Sie viel billiger bezahlen. Ich habe ein Institut in Taiwan zum Beispiel, da kostet ein wunderbar ausgebildeter Naturwissenschaftler ein Drittel sozusagen davon.
Das nicht, aber das Know-How aus dem ganzen Blame und Shame, dieser ganze Weltuntergang, das jetzt umzusetzen in Qualität, das ist jetzt notwendig, denn sonst fehlt uns die industrielle Basis dafür, das zu machen. Wie gesagt, wir haben halt die falschen Dinge perfektioniert und dadurch eben konkurrieren die neuen Cradle to Cradle Dinge mit hocheffizienten falschen anderen Dingen. Also ein Katalysator zum Beispiel in PET, der taucht in keiner Ökobilanz auf, weil er ja nur 500mg ist, also ein halbes Gramm pro Kilo. Und es taucht nur ab einem bestimmten Prozentsatz in der Ökobilanz auf. Das ist schon absurd für sich. Das wäre so wenn Sie jemanden anschauen, der ermordet wurde, und sagen, du siehst ja ganz gesund aus, das kleine Loch in der Stirn dazu macht doch eigentlich nichts oder? 99% bist du doch gesund.
Nein, wir haben einen Katalysator entwickelt, weil mir durch das Antimon in den Bremsbelägen aufgefallen ist, dass Antimon in vielen Bereichen verwendet wird, wie in PET zum Beispiel. Aus der Colaflasche wird das herausgelockt, bis zu 80 mal mehr Antimon ist in der Cola dann drin, wie es legal ist in Trinkwasser. Und dann sitzen wir mit Akzo Nobel hin, einen Katalysator zu entwickeln, der funktioniert und auch viel billiger ist noch und wo die Produktionsreste keine Abfälle sind. Trotzdem hat der bis jetzt gebraucht, über 24 Jahre auf den Markt zu kommen, weil der bestehende Katalysator Lebensmittelzulassung hat und weil die Cola-Leute ganz frech sagen, wir verkaufen kein Trinkwasser, wir verkaufen ja Coca Cola. Also müssen wir die Trinkwassergrenzwerte nicht einhalten, obwohl das Antimon genauso krebserzeugend ist im Trinkwasser und die Amerika trinken Cola wie Trinkwasser sozusagen. Das heißt es ist völlig zynisch.
Aber zunächst schützen sich die in den USA durch Nichtwissen. Also ich war dort und dann sagen die, Antimon haben wir noch nicht gehört. Und dann wiederhole ich es dreimal, dann sagen die, macht doch nichts, wir haben Lebensmittelzulassung, das ist das staatliche Problem. Der hat es zugelassen, das kümmert uns doch eigentlich nicht. Und der andere sagt, das ist ja kein Trinkwasser. Also müssen wir auch die Trinkwassergrenzwerte nicht einhalten. Und wenn Sie es also wirklich auf das Detail naturwissenschaftliche Problem zurück kriegen. Der neue Katalysator kommt jetzt erst auf den Markt durch Nestlé. Ich weiß zu Nestlé nicht viel positives zu sagen, aber da gibt es einen mutigen Menschen.
Also Katalysator als chemischer Katalysator in der Produktion von Flaschen meinen Sie?
Ja, wenn man PET herstellt, dann muss man, um den Kunststoff herzustellen, eine Nähmaschine praktisch verwenden, um die verschiedenen Kunststoffmoleküle in Ketten zusammen zu bringen. Das ist ein Katalysator, der ermöglicht die Reaktion daraus. Das ist ein giftiges Schwermetall, krebserzeugend und das muss ersetzt werden, weil sonst die ganzen Lebensmittel, auch alles Recycling, auch die Textilien daraus kontaminiert sind. Das funktioniert zwar wunderbar, aber das ist das Falsche halt perfekt. Und dann kann ich natürlich die Antimonmenge reduzieren und sonst was. Nein, wir sagen, es braucht einen Katalysator, der wirklich erlaubt, dass das PET nachher ...
Kleidung dann vor allem, weil ja aus solchen Flaschen dann teilweise dann wieder Fließjacken gemacht werden etc.
Ja klar, auch die ganzen anderen Polyester enthalten eben, PET ist ein Polyester sozusagen, enthalten auch diesen Antimon-Katalysator. Trevira oder sonst was zum Beispiel auch. Und das muss geändert werden. Und wenn das Bestehende optimiert ist, dann ist es schwer, die neuen Dinge auf den Markt zu kriegen. Und darum braucht es jetzt durchaus eine öffentliche Diskussion über Ziele. Wenn man sagt, wir möchten in fünf Jahren, dass alle Polyester einen gesunden Katalysator drin haben, dann die Industrie kann das von sich aus selber, dann kann man mit den Routineumstellungsprozesses dieses ändern. Und dann kostet das auch gar nicht mehr, weil man die Anlagen sowieso austauschen muss irgendwann.
Das ist ja sicherlich jetzt auch nochmal ein interessanter Bereich, wo wir vielleicht zum Ende nochmal drauf eingehen sollten, Sie stehen ja mit Ihrer Arbeit auch sehr in der Öffentlichkeit. Haben damit ja offensichtlich auch wenig Probleme. Ich würde fast unterstellen, auch ein bisschen Spaß. Wie gehen Sie also mit welcher Art von Kritik fühlen Sie sich in dieser Debatte primär konfrontiert und wie gehen Sie um? Ich könnte mir vorstellen, dass häufig so Hinweise kommen wie, naja das sind ja alles ganz nette Ideen, aber das funktioniert ja nicht im großen Stil und das kann man vielleicht mal hier partiell ausprobieren, aber die industriellen Anforderungen sind ja ganz andere. Also abgesehen jetzt von der reinen Argumentation im Bezug auf solche Fragen, wie gehen Sie generell auch damit um mit der Debatte?
Ich meine die einzige Kritik, die es tatsächlich gibt, ist von Leuten, die sich das nicht angeguckt haben, was Cradle to Cradle wirklich ist. Denn wenn man einmal verstanden hat, dass weniger schlecht nicht gut ist, dann möchte man mit weniger schlecht nicht weiter machen. Wenn ich mein Kind nur fünf mal schlage anstatt zehn mal, dann habe ich mein Kind nicht geschützt, sondern nur weniger kaputt gemacht. Wenn wir verstehen, dass wir zu viele sind, wenn wir den Planeten praktisch nur ein bisschen weniger zerstören. Ein Kind braucht etwa 5000 Windeln, wenn ich es um 10% reduziere, habe ich damit wirklich etwas erreicht? Wenn ich aber die Windeln zum Beispiel so mache, dass die Wasserspeicher keine Polyacrylate sind, die nachher nicht nur in Sondermüllverbrennungsanlagen verbrannt werden können, sondern aus Zellulose basiert, biologisch abbaubar sein können und die Kunststoffe entweder abtrennbar oder abbaubar sind, dann kann ich in Israel oder in Tunesien, in Ägypten mit einem Baby 150 Bäume pflanzen.
Dann ist das Baby kohlenstoffpositiv. Das heißt wenn man es einmal verstanden hat, für das ganze Leben ist es dann kohlenstoffpositiv. Wenn ich nur einmal verstanden habe, dass wir nützlich sein können, anstatt weniger schädlich, dann setzt sich das um. Es gibt nur fünf Arten, die Menschen zu kontrollieren, wenig schlecht zu sein. Aber Millionen Arten Menschen zu unterstützen, gut zu sein. Daraus entstehen halt einfach viele Innovationen, die hochprofitabel sind. Also die können hoch komplexe Produkte wie Fernseher, wie Staubsauger, wie Waschmaschinen inzwischen nach Cradle to Cradle machen. Und es entstehen auch Produkte, die profitabel sind, extrem profitabel. Also ein Hersteller, der Teppichböden macht, die nicht nur nicht stinken, sondern eben die Luft aktiv reinigen, erzielt eine Umsatzrendite so wie Apple. Dabei für ein Standard industrielles Produkt, ein Hersteller für Papierhandtücher erzielt fast 20% Umsatzrendite für Papierhandtücher, weil natürlich das System mitgedacht wird.
Also dort steht dann am Spiegel dran ein kleines Schild, bitte waschen Sie die Hände gründlich, wir möchten das Papier zurück. Und es wird dafür gemacht. Der Nassfestigkeitsstabilisator ist nicht mehr ein Chlorkohlenwasserstoff, sondern ein stärkebasiertes Molekül, was wieder zurück das Papier einsetzen kann. Vorher haben Sie jeden Dreck der Welt in den Papierhandtüchern drin. Ein Schlamm, den Sie teuer verbrennen müssen. Mit Rasierklingen und Kondomen und Tampons und jedem Dreck der Welt und Kaugummis. Und jetzt kriegen Sie ein völlig sauberes Substrat, was Sie wieder einsetzen können. Und die Leute waschen mit einem Schmunzeln die Hände wie im Chirurgenlehrfilm, damit das Papier wirklich so ist. Wenn Sie den Leuten die Chance geben, dann wollen sie gut sein und nicht weniger schlecht.
Ja gut, aber in dieser Auseinandersetzung mit der Industrie und mit der Politik, wo man es mit Lobbykräften zu tun hat, das kennt man ja auch aus anderen Bereichen zu Hauf, allein gute Argumente haben und eine positive Vision haben reicht ja nun nicht immer. Weil die Leute dann einfach sagen, nö trotzdem nicht.
Wie geht man das an?
Bei der letzten Chemienobelpreisträgertagung war ich der einzige Nichtnobelpreisträger, der dort eingeladen wurde, einen Vortrag zu halten vor 800 jungen Leuten, bei 32 Chemienobelpreisträgern sonst, weil es geht um gute Naturwissenschaft, sonst um gar nichts. Ein Produkt was sich in Muttermilch wiederfindet ist einfach nur schlechte Chemie, sonst gar nichts. Und das leuchtet schon ein. Und da ich von frühester Zeit und drum am Anfang erklärt, nie gedacht habe, dass ich moralisch besser bin als jemand anders, weil ich habe zuliebe meiner Chemielehrerin mich für Chemie interessiert. Ich habe auch zu Green Peace Zeiten nie gemeint, ich bin jetzt der tolle, edle, gute Umweltschützer, sondern ich habe mich immer nur geärgert über die Primitivität der Materialwissenschaften, die dahintersteckt und sonst nichts. Ich war einfach nur, wenn man so doof ist, Chemikalien zu machen, die sich in Muttermilch anreichern, dann ist man einfach ein Idiot.
Ja gut, aber wenn Sie jetzt ein Gespräch mit einem Politiker führen, und der Politiker sagt, ja Herr Braungart das ist ja alles schön und gut und das klingt ja ganz toll, aber mir haben meine ganzen Lobbyisten gesagt, das wäre alles Humbug.
Das gibt es eigentlich nicht. Erstaunlicherweise sagen die Leute dann, ja das ist Vision, das ist das höchste, was sie sich noch erlauben. Leute, die wirklich Cradle to Cradle begriffen haben, unterstützen das aktiv. Nehmen Sie den IG-Metall Vorsitzenden zum Beispiel, hier besser statt billiger sozusagen, die Gewerkschaft macht das. Nehmen Sie den Präsidenten der Industrie- und Handelskammer, den Erik Schweizer, überall macht der Werbung für Cradle to Cradle, als die Zukunft der Industrie. Nehmen Sie den EU-Kommissionspräsidenten, der hat gerade den Bürgermeister von Fenloe begrüßt. Der Herr Junker sagt, Sie machen doch Cradle to Cradle, das war der erste Satz .dazu Das heißt das wird jetzt eher so ein Hype, dass wir eher ein Qualitätsproblem kriegen, also es manchmal mehr Knödel to Knödel oder Nudel to Nudel. Wir haben so schnell eine Änderung jetzt nach Cradle to Cradle in Europa, dass die Leute eben Qualitätsprobleme haben.
So wie in der französischen Revolution, da haben sie sich gegenseitig geköpft, also da ist nichts dabei. Ist auch nicht, die Leute nehmen dann Teile heraus, die sie nicht verstanden haben und prügeln dann ein bisschen ein als Popanz, aber da ist ... - weil ich sage zum Beispiel, die Natur spart nicht, sie verzichtet nicht, sie vermeidet nicht, wenn sie genügend Energie hat, sie ist immer verschwenderisch. Und dann sagen die, nein wir müssen jetzt doch vermeiden und reduzieren und der Planet hat Grenzen. Was für eine Dummheit. Die einzige Grenze ist wirklich unsere eigene Dummheit, weil wenn wir den Energieüberschuss, nur jetzt nochmal zurück, den wir haben auf der Erde, in Materialintelligenz umsetzen, das ist die einsteinsche Formel. Letztlich darauf bezogen. Dann können wir leicht einen Planeten schaffen, der fünf Planetenäquivalenten entspricht. Also wir können einen viel viel produktiveren Planeten schaffen, ohne dass wir nur einen einzigen Baum abholzen, ein einziges Feuchtgebiet noch zerstören.
Es ist wirklich die einzige Begrenzung sind hoch optimierte falsche Systeme und daran müssten wir arbeiten. Jetzt wirklich durch Produkte, die wir zeigen, durch Kongresse. Es gibt in dem Crade to Cradle Verein arbeiten jetzt hunderte von jungen Wissenschaftlern mit. Überall kann man sich dem anschließen, ob in Frankfurt oder Stuttgart oder in Berlin oder wo man immer sein möchte, kann man mitmachen an Cradle to Cradle, Gruppe zu machen. Weil man alles wie mit den runden Tischen in der DDR sozusagen die Dinge nochmal neu erfinden und diskutieren muss.
Was ich mir ja ganz gut vorstellen kann ist, dass wenn das jetzt schon soviel Anklang findet, wie Sie sagen, dass das natürlich dann so schnell so ein Etikett wird wie Grün, Bio, Öko, schützt die Umwelt, schützt was weiß ich alles, ohne dass das eben auch so ist. Ich meine ich kann ja schnell da hingehen und sagen, ja hier wir haben das jetzt mit der modernsten C2C-Technologie optimiert und deswegen können Sie jetzt mit diesem 500 PS Auto so viel durch die Gegend fahren wie Sie wollen, ist alles total super, geht direkt wieder in Nilpferde über. Wer kontrolliert das und welche Mechanismen sind erforderlich, damit das nicht aus dem Ruder läuft?
Naja das einzige ist doch, dass wir nur Transparenz darüber brauchen.
In welcher Form?
Wir brauchen, dass die Unternehmen vorschlagen, wo sie sein wollen 2030. Die jetzige Nachhaltigkeit macht den Kunden zum Feind. Die sagt, wenn du es gar nicht kaufst ist es noch viel besser, musst du es wirklich haben? Wir sagen, lasst uns doch überlegen, wie in 20-30 Jahren eine Welt aussieht, die wirklich für 10 Milliarden Menschen da ist. Und dann ist natürlich ein Fahrzeug mit 800 PS, weil die Leute irgendwelche Potenzängste haben, natürlich eher ein Fall für den Therapeuten als was anderes dazu. Wir probieren das ja auch aus mit den anonymen Autostreichlern zum Beispiel.
Anonyme Autostreichler?
Auf der Reeperbahn. Was haben die Leute so große Autos? Ich meine jetzt nicht die, die wirklich beruflich genötigt sind, ihr Büro damit zu machen, sondern das sind Leute, die elementare Ängste haben, die sich unsicher fühlen, die kontaktgestört sind, die einen Panzer um sich herum brauchen. Die müssen therapiert werden, anstatt dass man sie noch zusätzlich als Umweltschweine anprangert. Ja da sind vor Nobeldiskotheken junge Männer und Frauen, die streicheln den Leuten über den Kopf und sagen, brauchst du doch gar nicht, du bist doch auch so ganz toll. Können uns am Wochenende treffen, ein Ferrari, ein Bugatti, gemeinsam streicheln und uns über Seelen und sinnliche Erlebnisse unterhalten. Denn das eigentliche Problem ist, da war eine Umwertung in der Anerkennungsgesellschaft. Denn warum braucht ein VW doppelt so viel PS wie vor 20 Jahren? Ist doch albern, um im Stau nur mithalten zu können mit dem anderen nebenbei?
Das heißt wenn Sie das machen, wenn Sie sagen, ich bin kein Zuhälter, ich brauche kein solches Auto, dann ändern Sie den Wert. Wer will denn schon Zuhälter sein? Das heißt darum gibt es ja auch bei jungen Leuten lange eine Umwertung was das Auto angeht. Das ist schon lange nicht mehr das allerhöchste sozusagen, weil es ist die Frage, komme ich von A nach B. Also wie sieht Mobilität dazu aus? Es gibt dann durchaus auch für das Auto noch Zukunft, dass man dann sich nicht täuscht. Weil der durchschnittliche Porschekäufer ist 59 und wir haben immer mehr 59-Jährige sozusagen. Und natürlich nehmen mit dem Alter die Potenzängste auch zu, also dafür braucht es auch solche Autos. Das ist schon okay. Also ich sage nur, es braucht mehr als die Naturwissenschaft dabei. Weil wir sind soziale Wesen und für uns wird jetzt in der Gesellschaft Anerkennung viel wichtiger. Warum stürzen sich die Leute auf Straßen und reißen sich um Asylanten, weil sie dadurch in ihren Netzwerken Anerkennung kriegen daraus.
Wir sind nicht die edlen Menschen, die das tun, weil sie machen das deshalb, weil sie für sich selber, auf sich selber stolz sein wollen zunächst mal. Also auch die Moral ist im Prinzip nur eine höhere Form der Eitelkeit sozusagen.
Zum Abschluss, Sie haben ja gesagt, Sie sind selber ein bisschen überrascht, kann ich das so deuten?
Ja.
Von dem Impact, den Ihre Ideen dort getragen haben und sicherlich auch noch von anderen Wissenschaftlern getragen werden. Wenn Sie das jetzt mal wieder mit einrechnen, wie schnell kann es denn jetzt weitergehen? Was denken Sie, sind denn so die nächsten Meilensteine, die unter Umständen genommen werden können, auch wenn Sie da ursprünglich so nicht mit gerechnet haben?
Ja wir brauchen jetzt schon klare Vorgaben. Wir müssen sagen, 2020 wird alles Papier in Europa kompostierbar sein. Denn schon jetzt fliegen die Leute die Druckerzeugnisse aus China ein und die sind 40% billiger. Und sie enthalten eben 90 giftige Stoffe, anstatt 50 giftige Stoffe. Das heißt wir verlieren dann die Vitalität, weil wir das High-Tech-Recycling für die 90 giftigen Stoffe machen. Das heißt wenn jetzt die Gesellschaft nicht diskutiert und positive Ziele setzt, dann wird die Druckindustrie weg sein. Es sind in der Schweiz in den letzten zwei Jahren ein Drittel aller Druckbetriebe verschwunden. In Deutschland etwa 20%. Das heißt die Industrie verliert dann die Vitalität. Sehen wir so im Textilbereich zum Beispiel, für die sind 5000 Euro inzwischen viel Geld. Das heißt wir wissen dann wie es geht, aber wir müssen warten, bis in China wieder sozusagen erst mal 40 Jahre Weltuntergangsdiskussion geführt wurde. Und die Zeit haben wir nicht. Wir müssen jetzt wirklich die Blaupause liefern, die in China kopiert werden kann.
Und da braucht es wirklich jetzt entschiedenes Vorgehen. Das heißt wir müssen jetzt wirklich sagen, was sind unsere Ziele, was wollen wir erreichen? Trotzdem glaube ich, dass man das ziemlich lustig auch machen kann. Also ich kann zum Beispiel die Kreislaufwirtschaft ist so einfach, Sie müssen nur Austern essen zum Beispiel, dann nehmen Sie 1500 Plastikteile aus dem Ozean zurück oder Sie können Ihren Carbon-Footprint reduzieren, wenn Sie nur Aufzug fahren. Also wir haben eine derartig perverse Landwirtschaft, dass wir für eine Kalorie Ernährung zehn Kalorien Energie brauchen.
Wenn ich Aufzug fahre?
Ja, weil wie gesagt, um mich zu ernähren, braucht für eine Kalorie Ernährung zehn Kalorien Energie. Wenn ich Aufzug fahre brauche ich nur umgerechnet für den gleichen Energieaufwand zwei Kalorien, anstatt zehn. Das heißt wenn ich um den Faktor 5 meinen Carbon-Footprint verbessern will, dann muss ich nur Aufzug fahren. Außerdem sterbe ich dann früher und schütze die Umwelt noch mehr in der Logik. Also da gibt es viele Dinge. Wenn Sie von Frankfurt zum Beispiel nach New York fliegen und alle Leute müssen ja wegen Sicherheitsgründen früher da sein und dafür eine Abführtablette nehmen und Ihren Magen-Darm-Trakt leeren, dann können Sie damit fünf Tonnen Kerosin einsparen. Also jeder kann was tun. Und weil die Leute zum shoppen ja rüberfliegen, können sie nackt hinfliegen, dann sparen sie nochmal zwei Tonnen Kerosin. Also jeder kann was tun, wenn er wirklich nur die Welt retten will. Und ich glaube, also es braucht vor allem halt, - die bestehenden Dinge sind so lustig primitiv, dass man eigentlich erst mal viel weiter käme, sich über die jetzige Absurdität zu unterhalten.
Denn dann würde man den Prozess schneller beschleunigen, als nur Produkte zu machen. Weil die Produkte setzen sorgfältige wissenschaftliche Arbeit voraus. Sie sehen hier in dem Raum immerhin etwa 400 Produkte nach Cradle to Cradle allein hier nur ausgestellt.
Also hier in Ihrem Showroom, wo wir uns gerade befinden.
Ja in dem Schauzimmer. Zum Beispiel ein Surfwachs, finden Sie irgendwie zunächst mal komisch, aber wenn Sie ein Surfwachs zum Surfen verwenden davon hier aus Kalifornien, das ist mir halt sehr aufgefallen, dann kommt die Firma an und dann mein Cradle to Cradle Surfwachs machen und sie muss die Paste komplett neu erfinden dafür. Weil der gleiche Überzug was auf dem Surfbrett passiert, findet auch auf dem Korallenriff statt. Jetzt haben wir ein Surfwachs, was perfekt in die Biosphäre zurückgeht. Völlig reversibel. Und das heißt es ist eine Innovation, die sich zunächst einfach anhört, aber die sehr viel komplexe Arbeit mit sich braucht, weil ich jede Zutat dann heraussuchen muss positiv. Und was mich ein bisschen irritiert ist, dass wir ein bisschen weiter sind als Green Peace zum Beispiel. Green Peace macht eine Detox-Kampagne. Sagt, hier sind 200 Chemikalien, die sollen nicht mehr verwendet werden, detox.
Dann unterschreibt Adidas und Puma und Nike, diese 200 Chemikalien werden wir nicht mehr verwenden. Dann kommen aber 200 andere. Das ist ein Hase und Igel Spiel. Dann würde ich lieber in meinem Alter eine Botox-Kampagne machen, da hätte ich wenigstens was davon sozusagen. Wissen Sie, das heißt wir müssen in den Kleidern, Textilien das sind 20.000 Chemikalien, ein Drittel aller Chemikalien werden im Textilbereich verwendet. Im Textilbereich arbeiten weltweit 15 mal mehr Menschen als in der Automobilindustrie zum Beispiel. Die ist bei weitem die wichtigste Industrie. Wir müssen positiv definieren was drin ist. Denn wenn die Kinder eine Allergie kriegen, Neurodermitis kriegen, weil sie den Dreck auf der Haut tragen, dann fehlt ihnen die Vitalität bei Jugend forscht mitzumachen oder so was. Wenn Sie Asthma haben, dann fehlt Ihnen das.
Also darum brauchen wir wirklich direkte Dinge. 40% unserer Häuser haben Schimmel zum Beispiel. Schimmel macht Asthma bei Kindern. Ist ein Naturstoff, aber wenn wir sagen würden, wir möchten bis 2020, dass kein Haus in Deutschland Schimmel mehr hat, dann könnten meine jungen Wissenschaftler eine positive Aufgabe damit verbinden und Lösungen dafür finden. Das heißt wir müssen jetzt gesellschaftliche Ziele diskutieren und dann packen wir das auch. Und wir haben natürlich jetzt durch die Wiedervereinigung viel viel Geld und viel viel Zeit verloren, weil wir jetzt sagten, das können wir uns jetzt gerade nicht erlauben. Jetzt wird durch die Finanzkrise und durch Griechenland und durch die Flüchtlingskatastrophen viel Vitalität und Zeit verloren gehen. Und so weit ist es ein spannendes Spiel, ob wir es packen. Das ist eine echte sportliche Herausforderung.
Ein Teil davon muss auf jeden Fall die Wissenschaft liefern. Und wenn ich mir das jetzt so alles durch den Kopf gehen lasse, worüber wir gesprochen habe, sehe ich vor allem die eigentlich sehr angenehme Vorstellung, dass man als Wissenschaftler heute eigentlich durch diesen Cradle to Cradle Ansatz im Prinzip jedes Produkt nochmal komplett neu erfinden kann und wahrscheinlich auch sollte, was natürlich auch sehr viel spaßiger und herausfordernder ist, als wenn man immer nur sich sozusagen in diese Tradition stellt mit, wie man es schon immer gemacht hat und dann füg ich dem vielleicht nochmal 5% Veränderung herbei.
Ja das schöne ist halt, bisher die Designer haben sich bisher hauptsächlich als Behübscher verstanden. Jetzt wird aber in jeder Designschule der Welt, die etwas auf sich hält, Cradle to Cradle gelehrt und es gibt jetzt junge Designer und Chemiker und Biologen und Physiker sind letztlich gesehen auch Designer, Gestalter ihrer Umwelt. Und die sagen dann, dieses Gucci-Täschchen Weichmacher, die unfruchtbar machen, ist ja toll. Das kannst du dir zu Hause auf den Nachttisch legen, dann kannst du dir die Stimme sparen sozusagen. Die bestehenden Dinge sind so extrem primitiv, dass all das was die jungen Leute machen so wie bei der Entwicklung des Internets, so wie bei der Entwicklung des Smartphones, so neu und anders sind, dass man die ganzen alten Säcke sofort vom Thron stoßen kann und sagen kann, was der Kaiser ist doch nackt, da ist ja gar nichts dahinter. Das ist nur ein Haufen Giftmüll.
Und will ich wirklich auf meine Haut einen Haufen Giftmüll bringen? Das heißt es setzt sich vor allem durch, weil die jungen Leute damit von Vornherein sehr einflussreich werden und sehr stark. Und es feiert die Naturwissenschaften und die Ingenieurwissenschaften, aber es setzt voraus, dass wir eben wirklich die Natur nicht romantisieren, sondern wirklich verstehen, dass nur durch die Naturwissenschaften und die Ingenieurwissenschaften die Welt ein so viel besserer Platz geworden ist. Warum haben wir die Natur so zerstört? Weil sie uns jämmerlich, übelst gemein behandelt hat. Und weil wir das bewusst wahrgenommen haben, mussten wir uns dagegen einfach wehren. Wenn wir uns in den Finger geschnitten haben, wussten wir nicht, ob wir den nächsten Tag überleben. Die sind an den jämmerlichsten einfachsten Dingen zugrunde gegangen. Noch bei meinem Großeltern, da sind von 13 Kindern 5 gestorben. Ich meine Mutter Natur? Nein, überhaupt nichts. Nur die Emanzipation ist jetzt vorbei.
Wir haben die Natur zerstört, weil sie uns zerstört hat, weil sie nicht freundlich zu uns war. Aber jetzt können wir lernen, die Natur als Partner zu verstehen, weil sie hat einfach durch die Evolution so einen wahnsinnigen Vorsprung, und dieses jetzt zu lernen und pure Naturwissenschaft zu begreifen, hat eine riesen Perspektive und ich kann nur sagen, ich hoffe, dass ich mal mit der Chemieindustrie und mit der Autoindustrie gemeinsam in die Hochschulen gehen kann und sagen kann, liebe Leute, kommt lasst uns das neu nochmal machen. Und in die Gymnasien und in die Kindergärten und dann packen wir das. Und dann staunen wir wieder über die Natur und staunen auch über uns selber, was wir alles machen können.
Ich fasse zusammen, der Kaiser ist nackt und die Selfie-Generation feiert sich demnächst im Netz, weil sie den Status Quo entsorgt hat und alles neu erfunden hat. Herr Braungart vielen Dank für das Gespräch.
Danke auch.